standing in the dark staring into a
mirror summoning Bloody Mary by chanting
her name is a terrifying classic
sleepover ritual here's the basic
premise if you chant Bloody Mary while
looking in a mirror in a dark room
preferably a bathroom the face of the
spectral woman will appear alongside you
the mirror is a symbol of Revelation and
self-reflection it forces us to see what
others see in fiction mirrors and
Reflections often serve as tools for
confrontation like in Harry Potter or
Snow White even when serving as portals
or Windows to Alternative worlds like an
Alice Through the Looking Glass or
Oculus the Journey of self-discovery or
Revelation is Paramount
with Bloody Mary that truth might just
be a good fright or her appearance might
tell your future Grant you a wish or
perhaps even kill you
I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is monstrum
if you were unlucky enough to summon
Bloody Mary there's no real standard of
what you'll see by some accounts she's
hideously mutilated but in others she is
beautiful but bloody more commonly
though every aspect of her appearance is
vague her spectral origin story is all
over the place too she Is tragically
disfigured and out for revenge or she's
been killed by a jealous lover there's
even versions where she was a witch
burned at the stake in Salem in some
Legends she's connected to a cult
where she comes from and what she looks
like is less important than the ritual
that summons her three things are almost
always required a dark room a mirror and
a chant you have to say her name
anywhere from three to a hundred times
and in some accounts you must have a
single candle burning in others the
summoning must occur in a bathroom a few
Tales even specify you have to run water
flush the toilet or spin around three
times still others note that you must
run out of the room when you see her or
she can cause you harm and in some
versions of the legend you even have to
offer your own blood what happens from
there she might reveal your future but
in most stories she's threatening she
will frighten you out of the room or
even attack you in the real world in one
particularly gruesome variation if you
touch the mirror she will be able to
drag you into her realm and kill you
sound ambiguous yeah that's kind of the
point at least in my mind not knowing
exactly what is going to happen or who
was going to appear in the mirror is
part of the attraction of this Legend
and a reason to try it yourself there
are three common elements to the legend
let's break it down first the dark room
fact it's scary to be in the dark
especially if you're asking for
something Supernatural to happen our
eyes tend to play tricks on us in the
dark seeing a distorted reflection in
the mirror is possible when darkness and
flickering light are in play in the case
of Bloody Mary overall spookiness and
fear are common culprits too second the
mirror mirrors serve as symbolic
boundaries spaces where the real is
confronted while offering the
possibility of alternative ways of
seeing or being after all there is the
idea of the mirror realm the basic
concept of the mirror realm is that
there is an opposite usually darker
world that exists alongside our own and
mirrors serve as the portals between the
two even before Bloody Mary entered into
the picture the idea existed that with
some kind of ritual other worldly
figures could appear inside of mirror in
some lore a malicious magic practitioner
could even bind a spirit or the devil to
a mirror as a threat of real persecution
for witchcraft declined the idea of a
cult play or lighthearted dabbling in
occult and magical practices Rose in
popularity young adults particularly
women turned to the mirror for
divination rituals often with the
intention of identifying their future
spouse knowledge of these playful
rituals was popular enough that in the
early 20th century as the postcard
industry boomed cards depicting women
engaging in divination rituals were
popular during The Fall season often
corresponding to Halloween
in one example a girl stands in front of
mirrors holding a candle while the
nebulous face of a handsome male figure
appears over her shoulder but not all
cards show such appealing prospects
other versions show a stereotypical
witch or the frightening ghost of a man
connecting the mirror ritual back to its
more nefarious associations it's hard to
guess how seriously rituals like these
were taken although the playful
commodification of the events suggests
at least some level of Carefree
participation the mirror ritual offers a
form of boundary Rebellion with little
risk of true danger an appealing
Prospect for teenagers and finally the
chant or what puts the Mary in Bloody
Mary the repeated name is always a
female one Bloody Mary of course but
also Mary worth Mary Ruth black Madam
Mary Lou Mary Johnson Mary weather and
Mary Wales for example Mary is a common
name but some of these women stand out
more than others in folklore take Mary
Wharf for example said to have a
Despicable injured face either from
genetics or a bad accident she resented
her looks so much so that she put a
curse upon the mirror she gazed into one
day and it shattered killing her if you
stare into a mirror and summon Mary
worth she will appear at a distance in
the reflection moving closer and closer
until she shatters the mirror and if
this happens you'll never again be able
to look into a mirror without seeing her
reflection or there's Mary Wales this
Mary was a young woman who was killed
when she was run over by a truck six
years after she died a couple saw her
trying to hitchhike bleeding in wet she
had scratches on her face you can look
in a mirror and summon her ghost by
saying I do believe in Mary whales
somewhere between 10 or 100 times given
the hitchhiking ghost element this urban
legend might be a regional variant
combining elements of other Legends and
monsters like the vanishing hitchhiker
LA yorona or Mary worth and let's
address the Royal elephant in the room
only one other female figure in history
has been called Bloody Mary Mary Tudor
or Queen Mary the first born to
Catherine of Aragon and King Henry VII
in 1516 Princess Mary was named after
her beautiful ant an attribute she came
to embody
scorned by her father upon his second
marriage she would eventually be
declared his rightful Heir in his will
and took the throne in 1553 her Reign
was fraught with tension at Mary's
command hundreds of Protestants were
burned at the stake as Heretics despite
this violence it wasn't until her
half-sister Queen Elizabeth's rule that
she would become known as Bloody Mary
likely as an attempt to diminish or at
least tarnish her historical
significance the catchy name gained
popularity as the 17th century war on so
by the time the infamous mirror
summoning postcards popped up in the
20th century the nickname had been
around for hundreds of years to me there
seems to be an easy connection between
the Royal and real Bloody Mary and the
folkloric monster both of their stories
deal with the cultural perception of
beauty and of Stories being Rewritten by
whomever is telling them casting the
Mary's as both victims and villains when
we consider where the summoning of
Bloody Mary often occurs in bathrooms
and by whom young women another
interpretation became comes apparent
bathrooms are uniquely liminal places
whether private or public they are rooms
within larger spaces where private acts
occur bodily functions often seen as
gross or taboo folklorist Alan Dundee's
Freudian reading of Bloody Mary proposes
a metaphorical representation to the
onset of menstruation he argues that the
mirror summoning ritual serves as a rite
of passage into puberty a journey that
is both feared and celebrated if we
accept this reading of the legend then
Bloody Mary is a warning not only about
the inevitability of the sudden bleeding
women will likely deal with in the
bathroom but of puberty in general an
adolescent girl gazing in the mirror may
be met with both trepidation and wonder
at her own changing appearance and
that's before you factor in the
pressures of an entire beauty industry
dedicated to making her want to alter
the reflection staring back at her not
to mention the expectations of whatever
standard of attractiveness is being
promoted in culture at the time perhaps
then it is unsurprising that the Mary in
the mirror is always frightening when
summoned it also helps explain why
Bloody Mary is a common figure at
sleepovers which often occur during
puberty and into the teen years telling
scary stories playing games and pulling
pranks are all common at sleepovers at
least the ones I went to and Bloody Mary
is an option that can fit into all three
categories for just the right age group
it's worth noting that the participant
in the Bloody Mary ritual is always in
control or appears to be they are the
one who says the name but they can also
turn on the lights or run away the ghost
is summoned it does not simply appear
unlike other monstrous spectral
encounters or ghostly women like the
Banshee or La yorona this notorious
female Specter must be invited in which
partially diminishes her power or at
least her reach and removes some of
Bloody Mary's potential to cause Terror
so our ability to control the appearance
of Bloody Mary takes a little bit of the
danger out of it fear becomes fun
the idea existed that with some kind of
ritual kind of ritual pause
really by the way but cut that